so why exactly was Dragonball super so
rushed okay so as some of you might know
I drew and covered a lot in the last
episode I assembled the team of wacky
talented mouse wielding Dragonball
artists and together we corrected some
of Dragon Ball super zwarst artwork in
addition to all of that I explained why
this show had some artistic troubles I
introduced many of you to incredible
artists working on the show and as many
of you pointed out I underwent some
serious character development when I
exposed a cringy old video I had made
however this week is gonna be different
but before I dive into that if you
haven't seen the first episode you can
click the top right and watch it right
now it might very well be my favorite
video I've ever made and this week I
don't think will be any different in the
comment section last time there were
once again more arguments over Dragon
Ball super production many people still
blaming the animators producers and
Towey at large for creating the bad
schedule they had to work with in the
first place
leading to tons and tons of poor artwork
produced over the course of the series
artwork I will attempt to correct today
once again who effort there's far far
too much for me to correct on my own and
so I'm gonna need to get the band back
together once again and that team is
anime AJ he's the brains of the
operation the vast majority of
information and research was supplied by
him and on top of that he's a great
artist to boot
despite his preference for ludicrous
point-and-click drawing equipment then
there's me totally not Marc he drives
the van and draws sometimes and to run
out the team we got Trent
he's pretty much the Brawn behind her
merry band of semi professional artists
he's incredibly quick and understands
how to mimic the character sheets of
Dragon Ball super with an accuracy so
perfect had I not touched his face in
person I would have said he was Teddy
Yoshi Emma Mauro in disguise oh and to
reiterate from the last video Teddy
Yoshi Mamoru is responsible for
dictating what battle of gods
resurrection F and Dragon Ball super
looked like he was their character
designer and corrected the two films
from top to bottom I'm serious he
corrected almost every single frame on
those things and in particularly every
episode of Dragon Ball super he provided
Corrections for as well in the last
video I wanted to introduce you guys to
a host of animators that worked a toy
mimicking their styles and trying to
explain to you all that the reasons
Dragon Ball super looked as bad as it
did was primarily down to time
restraints this week however we will be
correcting more drawings sticking closer
to the character sheets mimic
the main man himself tadayoshi mamuro
and we will be answering the age-old
question why was super rushed in the
first place
I had to kick things off the first one
to draw is me this original piece of
Dragonball artwork came from episode 23
and this portion of the show faced a ton
of trouble but in order to understand
why I need to take you all back in time
to the year 2014 an anime by the name of
Torico was on the air and don't worry if
you've never heard of it no one did and
that was the problem the ratings of the
show were super low and no one was
buying any of the merchandise and so
unfortunately for Torico fans the show
was cancelled in place of Torah code the
Buu saga of Dragonball Caillou was
slotted in previously only intended for
international audiences fast forwards in
2015 and resurrection F was released to
the world this movie took everyone at
Toei by surprise for some reason the
film was massively successful grossing
over 64 million dollars in the box
office making it the most profitable
Dragon Bowl film ever made at the time
funnily enough the episode I'm
correcting for right now happens to be
covering that exact same storyline and
while the fans didn't much care for
supers version of the story they very
much did for the film generating tons of
revenue for Toei remember now at this
point there's no plan for Dragon Ball
super Dragon Ball Kai is filling the
time slot and right after that Digimon
was looking to start its new series so
with no time slots available what does
Fuji TV and toee do they chuck hunt the
Digimon series replacing it with a short
series of movies called try and ten days
after the shockingly successful of
resurrection F film was released they
announced a new Dragon Ball anime that
everyone now knows as Dragon Ball super
which later spawned this lovely skinny
boy I am now finished correcting I'm
pretty happy with how it turned out and
next up the draw is
age this image was taken from the very
next episode after the Gohan correction
I did these really were dark times for
the series and the artist AJ is
correcting here is Yuka Hiro katana your
favorite animator in mind well AJ tangos
with this you could hear a katana
drawing let's try to answer these
questions resurrection F was a massive
hit and so they decided to make a new
anime great right Bandai had wanted a
new series for years and as had the fans
well turns out it was not so great this
was the moment that decided Dragon Ball
super is fate and perhaps not for the
reasons you might think this quick rush
to bring the series to air shattered
Dragon Ball super is pre-production
window and to put into perspective for
shows like my hero academia or JoJo's
Bizarre Adventure the time span from
announcement to air date is usually
around six months Dragon Ball super z'
was two months and any good
mathematician will tell you two is less
than six to illustrate how sudden and
out of nowhere supers announcement was
when it was announced there was no logo
no our work or anything just text as
time went on we would eventually get
unfinished versions of the logo and
pieces of artwork being made here and
there anyone that was in the know at
this point understood very well that
things were not good underneath the
surface things like this rarely happened
but given that toey already had stories
lined up to cover with the prior two
films already released character sheets
at the ready designs and locations done
it really was the perfect storm to
create something awful for Dragon Ball
super and its episodes like this one
that paid for it episode 24 of Dragon
Ball super was the roughest by a wide
margin in my opinion but thanks to AJ
and his mouse we have a fully colored
and corrected Frieza from episode 24
next up the draw is me and I'll be
correcting this shot taken out of Goku's
fight against boat amo in episode 33 I
don't think any fight boat amo has had
and super actually looked good so let's
see if I can change it with this shot
and for the love of all that is holy I
will try to fix this arm that looks like
it's being sucked into a vortex for
those of you out there that don't know
how Dragon Ball super would normally
produce episodes under ideal
circumstances two to three weeks if not
more will be set aside to build the
storyboards alone these are the panels
that make up the episodes and dictate
how interesting the angles might be
which directly informs fight
choreography like I'm dealing with right
now in this correction after these
storyboarding weeks are completed they
set aside about seven to eight weeks for
the animation process oftentimes more if
the episodes in question are
action-heavy episodes or if the schedule
is specifically very good Super's
pre-production window only gave them
enough time to finish two or three
episodes prior to the show hitting the
air breaking their schedule completely
and resulting in the infamous
action-heavy
episode 5 totally melted which in
reality was probably made in less than
three weeks if that which directly
translates to the entire episode
comprising itself largely of rough work
and unfortunately it looks like episode
33 met a similar fate
hopefully this correction helped fully
finished and colored Goku Kamehameha and
episode 33 and next up we have
[Music]
tackling episode 21s piccolo this one is
sort of a minor correction the drawing
in question is better than the others
we've covered prior and in fact
artistically there's not a whole lot
wrong
however context is important and
Corrections are often applied for these
reasons here piccolo supposed to be
reacting to Gohan's potential death and
it looks
maybe a little too goofy for that so
let's leave Trev to correct that
expression okay so some of you might
understandably be thinking maybe if Toa
dedicated more money and resources to
Dragon Ball super it would have improved
greatly this is widely known as the low
budget argument I mean it makes sense in
most industries particularly film having
more money tends to help with the
quality and polish of the overall
product but if something makes sense it
generally doesn't apply to the Japanese
animation industry sadly paying someone
to work more hours or hiring new staff
to work on the project might create more
movement on the screen in a very
technical sense of the word but unless
those artists have the time to create
the animation the movement itself will
suffer drastically to borrow an analogy
that AJ is used if I were to hire Gordon
Ramsay to make my dinner and told him
that he only had one minute to make me
something delicious do you think that
dinner would be a great demonstration of
how great a chef that man is the answer
is no because like hour at work food
preparation takes time in saying this
budget itself is an important component
when it comes to hiring talented
animators to work on the show and
especially the scope permitted for the
scenes but unless that talent has time
to work it'll always look subpar and
that's if you can even find the talent
in the first place however unlike supers
production Trev had loads of time to
complete this drawing and it's now
perfectly on model next up
be again in this one I'll be correcting
a close-up of Super Saiyan blue Kaioken
Goku from episode 40 this was once again
in action heavy episode that required
much more than what it ultimately got
but in speaking about the production
budget really has little to do with it
it largely boils down to time and talent
I mentioned in the last segment that
more people and more money does tend to
make the potential for more movement
however that doesn't always yield a
great result for instance this piece of
animation taken out of episode 26 shows
Frieza falling towards the camera with
Super Saiyan blue Goku in frame there's
lots of movement but the animation is
sort of broken while the artwork is
indeed very poor even if I were to go
and correct all of it myself it still
wouldn't animate well and would
therefore look awful and so that's what
I mean when I say money can buy the
potential for movement but it can't
guarantee its quality or character art
polish and speaking of character art I
think this one is done I correct it
pretty much the entire face as the angle
of the head was sort of off and there
you have it episode 40 has one more
panel to be happier with but the
correction that's up next is perhaps one
of the most difficult angles in all of
Dragonball and really drawing in general
and there's only one man for the job
[Music]
this shot in question comes from the
same episode I corrected just there
episode 40 however this angle is cruel
to say the least
it's a full body 3/4 up shot and while
being a tough pose in general it is
specifically for Dragon Ball which while
having a multitude of approaches are all
difficult to get right with most of them
looking extremely weird I think this is
an example of a storyboard that tries to
make the episode look interesting but
because it's difficult to draw drawing
it quickly becomes an die impossible and
so Trev is going to see if he can work
his magic on it funnily enough during
trebs recreation of this piece after he
had pretty much finished and colored the
entire thing something happened leading
to him losing the entire artwork
thankfully he was recording and so he
didn't lose everything but let that be a
lesson to you guys save often but there
you have it I gave a Moro style Goku at
a really tough angle nice work and next
up is
AJ this is AJ's last troika video and in
it he will be tackling this very rough
fat Goku and hopefully with the aid of
his trusty mouse will manage to produce
a fantastic correction close to the
style of the model sheets AJ himself has
a channel where I've gotten the vast
majority of this information used in the
video so if you'd like to learn more
about the individual episodes of supers
production I couldn't recommend it more
but more to the point the reason we
trying to fight back against the budget
argument as often as I do is simply
because it insinuates that Dragon Ball
super has a cheap production and nothing
could be further from the truth the way
a typical staff list on a super episode
would look assuming the production
schedule is healthy would be a bunch of
key animators working under a single
animation supervisor however as the show
progressed because there was simply too
much work to get through toey was forced
to spend a massive amounts of money on
as much human resource as they possibly
could this drastically drove up the
amount of money spent per episode and
guess what all this started happening
for the resurrection F Ark and as you
all know that doesn't look very good I
think the reason the budget argument is
so prolific is because it makes sense to
us you would think that if you need more
work done you just need to hire more
quality people and that would normally
be true if the work force you're looking
for wasn't specialized like animators
are likewise time is money and money is
time it's a popular quote but you cannot
invent time it's easy to say put the
show on hiatus until things get better
but ultimately Toey aren't the sole
creators of the show the network fuji TV
and merchandise company Bandai are all
on the production committee and have a
huge save due to their funding the show
Dragon Ball super simply was making too
much money in spite of the issues that
it made no business sense to stop it
money money money
as a result Dragon Ball super naturally
rapidly declined in quality and so the
only option was for Toey to employ a ton
of Studios across Asia outsourcing their
animation in order to try and finish
episodes on time along with splitting
the workload between multiple
supervisors to say that Toei animation
spared no expense with Dragon Ball super
would be an understatement
these patchwork fixes come at huge cost
thankfully however AJ had the luxury of
time on his side
producing a beautiful correction for
episode 72 and next up is me in this
correction I'll be attending to fix this
really janky Super Saiyan Goku dashing
towards the camera this was probably the
toughest correction I supplied for this
video and I am really happy with how it
turned out
but what I wasn't happy with was one of
the biggest lies to come out of Dragon
Ball super xanimation controversy and I
was at the expense of its own staff in
an interview with Anime News Network nor
Akira hayashida one of the producers
acto animation loved the blame for
supers bad animation on inexperienced
newbie animators despite hayashida
himself not actually working on super it
was simply a quick excuse in the heat of
the interview this is obviously
incorrect and anyone with a passing
interest and a quick Google search can't
confirm that the majority of super staff
were comprised of veterans in the
industry with super-strong portfolios
many staff like natasha shita tadayoshi
mamuro now quítate masa hiroshima nuki
and countless other animators had 20
plus years of experience including
extensive work on the other three Dragon
Ball series if we were to look at
episode 5 specifically the newest
animator on that staff listing had three
or four years of experience and were
right at the bottom of the staff list
which meant that they contributed very
little to the episode itself as Toei
orders their credits by the number of
cuts drawn within the episode itself you
have animators like Nikita and Ken
Otsuka who have both 20 years of
experience in the industry and if I
continue down the staff miss the
majority of them have at least 10 years
experience but in saying that this is my
correction Super Saiyan Goku dashing
towards the camera fully corrected for
episode 81 but who needs industry
experience where you've got thread this
time-travel be skipping ahead to episode
81 deep into the final arc of the series
trevally correcting this slightly derpy
Gohan and hopefully transforming it into
a perfectly unmodeled gym as I was
saying for noir hero hayashida to
suggest that this was the work of newbie
animators feels a lot more like shifting
the blame onto the staff that worked on
the show and away from the executives
who made the decisions to rush the
series into production but why not delay
it it seems like a simple fix well as I
suggested earlier for the same reason
companies do anything money
Dragon Ball after resurrection
was right in a resurgence in popularity
with the completion of Dragon Ball Kai
bringing a newer younger audience to the
product and resurrection F being the
smash hit that it was momentum was
firmly with the Dragon Ball brand and to
ignore that wouldn't make good business
sense for the advertising networking and
merchandising potential the new series
possessed and while the decision made
good business sense and ultimately led
to super becoming the most popular and
largest moneymaker in the anime industry
during the time I was on the air and
thereafter the conditions it forced the
staff to work through were nothing short
of unspeakable so personally for me to
listen to a toy higher up unload a bulk
of blame onto the overworked and
underpaid staff was too much and frankly
disgusting thankfully though this
correction from Trev was most certainly
not disgusting but instead fantastic and
perfectly on model
this will be my final drawing of the
video but with it I will be transforming
this weird bearest that looks like a dog
for some reason back into regular old
cat beerus taken from episode 82 this
was my very first time drawing beerus
and to be perfectly honest it would have
taken me a lot longer had it not been
for Trevon aj giving me a hand with it
Toyo Tara said himself that beerus was
one of the hardest characters for him to
draw and I definitely understand that
now I began the process by drawing with
the character sheets the animators would
be supplied with on the screen for me to
reference beerus has such a strangely
shaped head and getting it right while
not completely ruining the expression
from the original was a tough challenge
however eventually i did complete the
piece and end up very happy with the
final result so there it is completely
colored and fully corrected beerus the
god of destruction from episode 82 and
one thing I'd like to end on is an
answer to how Dragon Ball super started
to fix itself during the second half of
the series but before that TREB has a
special correction to make
during this video we've spent pretty
much the entire runtime trying to
replicate the style of the series
animation director ecaddy Yoshi Yamamura
but with this one we decided to break
that trend episode 122 while fantastic
largely thanks to the Corrections and
work supplied by Yuya Takahashi the
episode itself had its first half
handled by a different supervisor since
the schedule only allowed takahashi
enough time to do one half if you cast
your minds back this multitude of
supervisors sharing an episode was there
to help the show and so well it strikes
again and we thought it would be fun to
see how things might look if takahashi
had enough time for both halves so with
this one travel be taking Takashi
gnocchi's I was Goku mistakenly drawn
with Super Saiyan 2 hair and you you
finding it into Takahashi's goodness and
while he's doing that I will attempt to
answer a broad question which is how do
they improve it if they were in such a
bad situation well with great difficulty
again multiple supervisors would be
assigned to a single episode to watch
over instead of just one they would
outsource to other animation studios
across Asia with certain episodes having
as many as six external Studios working
on the mid ones this didn't do polished
results but it did free up the main
staff at Toei to work on the future
episodes to build more of a buffer or to
tackle more action
scenes they began relying more on Bank
animation to save them more time on
various scenes and action sequences to I
mean as I said in the prior video
episode 129 was largely made up of
reused animation and finally in addition
to all of that bunches of episodes had
to be made that offered little in the
way of movement to give more time to
those at Toa
to work on later episodes remember that
long stretch between the Future Trunks
arc and the universe survival arc it's a
total time saver and so over the course
of time it was in the air Dragon Ball
super eventually developed a better
schedule leading to the series ending
gracefully and strongly with episode 130
and 131 not only doubling the number of
frames allowed per episode but actually
having the time to use them producing
some of the best animation the franchise
has ever seen imagine the sort of work
they could have made with the
appropriate amount of time there
wouldn't be a need for this amazing
correction by Trev and certainly not
this video in recent times toy animation
has tried to alleviate its overworked
artists by preventing animators from
staying in the office beyond their
assigned hours and while all this sounds
lovely on paper the higher-ups didn't
move any of the deadlines these people
are asked to meet thus adding further
stress to their situations regarding
supers animation staff despite being the
target of scrutiny from both the public
and their internal higher-ups it is my
firmly held belief that Dragon Ball
super to this day stands as an
incredible example of tenacity and human
perseverance to meet the impossible odds
unfairly placed against them and to me
nothing is more dragonball than that
in this episode myself AJ and Trev
worked on 11 individual drawings each
taking us a lot of time to bring to the
satisfactory standard that you saw the
further emphasized how important the
working conditions of a studio really
are and why the ironist deserve to be
treated properly if they are to produce
good work here is the time it took us to
create these drawings once again I'd
like to thank Trev for his incredible
artwork and help in assisting me to
learn how to understand dragonballs art
design I'd also like to thank AJ for the
same reasons as well as helping me with
the script and providing virtually all
the information used in this video
quite literally these videos wouldn't
exist without them and you guys should
totally follow them on their social
medias the links are in the description
oh also while you're
the comment section and let us know
which one was your favorite correction
and why also please bully AJ on Twitter
about his insistence on drawing with a
mouse okay that'll do it for this week
I've been totally not mark thank you so
much for watching
[Music]
you